- [Instructor] So let's
see if we can figure out
what 1/3 divided by five is.
And I'll give you a hint.
Try to draw out 1/3 of a whole
and then divide it into
five equal sections.
Pause this video and try to do that.
I always try to work through it together
and to help us as I promised
or I suggested I guess.
We said let's draw 1/3.
I will represent a whole by
that square right over there.
And now let me split up
into three equal sections.
So this is all hand drawn
with the aid of a computer.
So it's not going to be perfect.
But let's say that that
is three equal sections.
It's roughly three equal sections.
I didn't do it perfectly
but you hopefully get the idea.
And so 1/3 would be one of
those three equal sections.
So that's a third right over there
that I have just shaded in
and I want to divide it into five.
I want to divide it by five, I should say.
So let's do that.
So to divide it by five, I'm
gonna divide it into five
equal sections.
And if I'm dividing that one
into five equal sections,
let me just divide all of the thirds
into five equal sections.
I'm essentially just going
to make five rows here.
One, and I'm gonna eyeball it,
so it's going to be approximate.
Two, three, and then four
and five equal sections.
I now split this whole into
one, two, three, four, five rows
of equal height.
Now if I go to my original
third and I divide it by five,
I would be left with this right over here.
But what fraction is this of the whole?
Well what I've done now
is I've split my whole
into 15 equal sections.
How do I know that?
Well I could count them.
One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15.
Or you could just say look
I had one, two, three thirds
and now each of those have been split into
one, two, three, four,
five equal sections.
So three times five is 15.
So each of these is a 15th
and so the 1/3 divided by five is just one
of those 15ths.
So that right over there
is one of those 15ths.
So this is going to be equal to 1/15
and we are done.